hello good
people of the interweb i'm dave rubin it
is october 16
2020. it's friday october 16
2020 and i normally don't do direct
message shows
on friday we've been doing the direct
message tuesday wednesday thursday
but joe biden and donald trump did
town halls last night and i felt that it
was important
that i get up put on a shirt and dissect
the town halls with you this morning
they were supposed to do
a debate last night remember that was
originally the plan that these two old
men were going to do a debate
after the last debate which was pretty
much a disaster on all fronts
then trump got coveted he got cured from
kovid they said they can't do a debate
it doesn't even really make any sense
because they obviously still could have
been standing there they could have had
a glass
shield and bulletproof glass in between
them they could have
you know just been 80 feet apart i mean
just
any sort of ridiculous thing whatsoever
they were going to do it digitally like
over zoom but then trump actually didn't
want to do that
which i think was probably a decent
choice to not want to do it on zoom
because
you just don't know what biden is
looking at either on a teleprompter or
or with the ifb
in the ear or the rest of it not to say
that trump couldn't do the exact same
things
but they felt that that wasn't the right
way to do it so then they just didn't
have a debate and instead
they both had town halls except
one of them wasn't really a town hall so
donald trump was on
nbc and he was moderated by savannah
guthrie
who who obviously is just a democrat
she's obviously a democrat i don't think
anyone is really thinking she's not a
democrat but she's a journalist i
suppose
and they did a town hall except it was
just her asking questions there were a
couple other people there but
it wasn't really a town hall i mean when
we think of a town hall
you think of a politician going out
there and there are people and you're
going to take questions and you're going
to engage and interact and the rest of
it
they called it a town hall but in
essence it was not a town hall it was
just a grilling
by savannah guthrie that was on nbc and
then over on abc at the exact same time
they had joe biden with george
stephanopoulos who's the head of the abc
news operation over there and hosts
their sunday night show
and uh it's important to remember that
george stephanopoulos the supposedly
you know uh bipartisan or non-partisan
host of this thing moderator of this
thing that he worked
in the clinton white house he was bill
clinton's communications
director and then after that i want to
get it right he was the senior advisor
for policy and strategy
for the bill clinton white house so do
you think he's a democrat
or a republican which would you think
there if he worked and was advising bill
clinton the democratic president on
policy
but now we're supposed to pretend that
he's non-partisan too and by the way i'm
not even saying that anyone is truly
non-partisan if you exist in the world
in the political world
and you you purport to be totally
non-partisan i have
no opinions or thoughts on anything well
then you're probably in the wrong
business right can i
i can tell you that there's there are
thoughts that i have and and feelings
that i have and
conclusions that i've come to that
sometimes uh align
well these days more often with
right-leaning things but some of the
things that i believe are thought of as
left-leaning things
and that's sort of a whole separate
discussion we could have about sort of
the nonsensicalness of left and right
these days because everything
is sort of out of control but i think
it's worth noting that george
stephanopoulos
is who's basically just a democrat was
the one doing the softball stuff with
with joe biden and trump had a very uh
contentious non-town hall with savannah
guthrie
so let's go to some videotape of what
happened last night
let's start with joe biden he was asked
a question
about transgender children um i'm the
proud mom
of two girls eight and ten
my youngest daughter is transgender
the trump administration has attacked
the rights of transgender people
banning them from military service
and weakening non-discrimination
protections
and even removing the word transgender
from some government websites
how will you as president reverse
this dangerous and discriminatory agenda
and ensure that the lives and rights of
lgbtq people are protected
under u.s law i will flat out just
change the law
every eliminate those executive orders
number one
you may recall i'm the guy who said i
was raised by a man
who i remember i was being dropped off
my my my dad was a
high school educated well-read man who
was a really decent guy and i was being
dropped off to
get an application in the center of our
city wilmington delaware
the corporate capital of the world at
the time and these two men i'm
getting out to get a an application to
be a lifeguard in the african-american
community because there was a big
swimming pool complex
and uh and these two men well-dressed
leaned up and hugged one and
kissed one another i'm getting out of
the car at the light and i turned to my
dad
my dad looked at me said joey it's
simple they love each other
the idea that an eight-year-old child or
a ten-year-old child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i think i'd like
to be
make my life a lot easier there should
be zero discrimination and what's
happening is
too many transgender women of color are
being murdered
they're being murdered i mean i think
it's up to now 17 don't hold me to that
number but it's
it's it's incred it's it's higher now
and
that's just this year and so i promise
you there is no
reason to suggest that there should be
any
right denied your daughter or daughters
whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero and by the way my son beau
passed away was the attorney general of
the state of delaware he was the guy who
got the first transgender law passed in
the state of delaware
and because of a young man who became
a woman who worked for him in the
attorney general's office
lordy lordy there's a lot to talk about
there
okay so first off apparently something
like
60 70 roughly years ago joe biden's
father
told him it's cool to see two men
kissing i mean that just sounds
completely made up
i suppose it's nice if it did actually
happen but it just sounds like just like
a made-up
politician story but let's just pretend
for a second before we get to the trad
stuff
but joe was in willington the corporate
wilmington the corporate capital of the
world and you know he sees
two men kissing and his dad says it's
wonderful and love is love
and you know the whole thing and okay
great right i know every one of you
watching this you don't care about gay
people and guess what gay people are
gonna kiss every now and again it's one
of the things that comes with being gay
and straight people kiss and
all right so be it um but if biden's dad
was so down with the gays back then and
and that was instilled in biden
literally it had to be 70 years ago
right the guy's 77 so he's about 7 years
old so about 70 years ago biden was
totally cool with the gays
except joe biden was not for gay
marriage even the first time around
in the obama presidency and there are
many
many videos of him in the senate doing
the defense of marriage act defending
the defense of marriage
act and talking about marriage between
one man and a woman so apparently he was
so
cool with it and his dad was really
ahead of his time and they're down with
men kissing
but apparently that didn't make it to
his public policy about whether
gay people should be an equal
relationship so that's just a little bit
about the hypocrisy there
on the stuff about the the transgender
stuff i mean look partly what's happened
here and and i've had many guests on the
show from deborah soh
and douglas murray and gad sad and peter
bogosian many of my guests have been
discussing this that we've somehow
made the trans issue sort of supersede
every other issue
and i know that and i think you know
that most gay people just wanted
equality under the law right just we
want equality to be in the same
equal marriage as straight people so we
can live the same boring
simple decent lives as everybody else
the trans issue seems to have become
something else but biden said some
strange things there
he said that uh if the eight-year-old
decides
to become transgender now i i thought
that
if lady gaga has taught us nothing it's
that you were born this way so biden
saying
you decide that an eight-year-old can
make some sort of conscious decision
to be transgender that just seems odd in
itself it seems particularly odd because
let's not forget guys it was only two
days ago
that during the amy coney barrett
hearings when she used the
phrase sexual preference which everyone
has
always used forever related to sexuality
and suddenly we were told it was
offensive and then
i kid you not this is not a joke please
google it miriam webster dictionary
literally two days ago changed the
definition of the word preference
to call it offensive in the dictionary
even though it had never been thought of
as offensive before in the context of
sexual preference
but so okay so sexual preference is now
offensive
but you can also decide to become trans
now i get it this is a little bit of
linguistic nonsense but it also goes to
show that biden doesn't really know what
he's talking about and i'm not even
making
that's not a joke about biden's
cognitive ability i think most people
related to this
don't know what's going on or know how
to use language properly
or anything else but he said if if they
decided to be trans or if the kids said
it would make my life a lot easier
what are you talking about what what
eight-year-olds walking around
going okay i'm gonna be trans and
because i'm
it's gonna be a lot easier i mean if
anything that that shows a complete
lack of sympathy for young trans people
but the bigger issue here with the trans
thing is that it's being pushed on us
as if it's something that should have
something to do with the president's
decision and i just want to be very very
clear on one thing if it seems that i'm
being cold or callous to
trans people i want trans people to live
with the exact same dignity
under the exact same laws as everybody
else
without question without exception and
by the way there's a video that i'm sure
many of you have seen
where i went to university of new
hampshire a couple years ago and there
were hundreds of protesters and they
were screaming that i'm a homophobic
nazi and
you know the usual nonsense and there's
a woman screaming at me that i hate
trans people and all this stuff
and it turns out that she was trans and
i kept saying well i hope you have
someone that you love in your life and i
want you to be treated with the same
dignity and respect as everyone else and
the same exact laws should apply to you
and i would never want you to be
discriminated against but she's still
calling me a nazi and a bigot and a
trans woman
it turns out that the woman was a gender
studies professor
at university of new hampshire who was
trying to silence a speaker and calling
a speaker a nazi as i'm telling her yes
you should be treated equally so
the the as you guys know the radical
movement
behind all of this is much worse
than the idea of trans people which
which if someone is trans if someone
feels that they were born in a body that
does not match their
their actual gender and they choose to
live a life
um as the other gender i'm completely
fine with that it's their choice
it's their choice in life right um but
so it's just it's just silly language
and nonsensical stuff
uh let's move on to we'll do one more on
biden before we get to trump
because this has been a big one lately
whether biden's gonna pack the courts so
let's
take a look here's what you said exactly
one year ago tonight at a democratic
debate
he said i would not get into court
packing i would not pack the court
that's not what you're saying now is the
nomination of judge barrett
reason enough to rethink your position
what is
the nomination that what i wanted to do
george you know if i had answered the
question directly
then all the focus would be on what's
biden going to do if he wins
instead of on is it appropriate what is
going on now
and it should stay this is the thing
that the president loves to do
always take our eye off the ball what's
at stake
one of the things peter suggested is and
there's a number of constitutional
scholars have suggested as well
that there are at least four or five
options that are available to determine
whether or not
you can change the way in which the
court lifetime appointment takes place
consistent arguably with the
constitution
i have not been a fan of pat court
packing because i think it just
generates what will happen
every whoever wins it just keeps moving
in a way that is inconsistent with
what is going to be manageable so you're
still not a fan well i'm not a fan i
don't say
it depends on how this turns out not how
he wins but how it's handled
how it's handled but there's a number of
things that are going to be coming up
and there's going to be a lot of
discussion about other alternatives as
well what does that mean how it's
handled
how will that determine well for example
there's actually
real wide debate on the floor if people
are really going to be able to have a
time to go through this
you know i don't know anybody who's gone
on the floor and just
and that's been a controversial justice
in terms of
making fundamentally altering the the
makeup of the court
that's gone through in a day kind of
thing i mean it depends on how much they
rush this
and you think about it george here you
got a lot of people not to be able to
pay their mortgage not be able to put
food in the table not be able to keep
their business open
not being able to do anything to deal
with what's going on in terms of the
economy as a consequence of covert
and they have no time to deal with that
but they have time
to rush this through well right now it
looks like they're going to have a vote
around halloween so if they vote on it
before the election if they vote out
before the election
you are open to expanding the court i'm
open to
considering what happens from that point
on
you know you've said so many times
during the campaign all through the
course of your career it's important to
level
it is but george if i if i say no matter
what answer i gave you
if i say it that's the headline tomorrow
it won't be about what's going on now
the improper way they're proceeding but
don't voters have a right to know where
you they do have a right to know where
they stand and i'll have a right to know
where i stand before they vote
so you'll come out with a clear position
before election day yes depending on how
they handle this
all right it ends up being about a six
minute answer that we're just showing
you a short clip of
uh but in case you're not clear yes they
will be packing the courts biden this
idea
really that you can't say what you're
going to do until you're voted in
is actually quite anti-democratic
actually because you vote for candidates
because they
they're supposed to promise you things
now
maybe you shouldn't get all the stuff
that you want from politicians maybe
that would be a good idea and we should
give these people less power over our
lives in general
i'd be for that um but he obviously will
pack the courts and and by the way this
is not something
that i think is being driven by joe
biden specifically this
is clearly like so much of the rest of
this this is driven by
the crazed progressives they want to
change every norm they would gladly pack
the courts
by the way there seems to be this
misnomer out there that republicans
who use their constitutional rights
to to put supreme court justices in to
give
judges jobs when there are vacancies
that that's packing the court no that's
actually what you're supposed to do
that's not packing the court packing the
court is when you expand the court
right when you expand the court that's
changing the whole game and they're
telling us the democrats are telling us
we want to change the court we want to
get rid of the electoral college
we want to do things that are
fundamentally different than how things
have always been done
and the reason biden won't say no i
won't do it even though i don't think
he wants to do it because i actually do
think biden cares about the constitution
um the reason he won't say it is he
doesn't want to alienate the base
so this is just one of those if you're
voting for biden and you think he isn't
going to pack the court
you're just me you're just wrong i mean
you're just wrong unfortunately he is
being
he is being led by by elements of the
party
that are not in line with what i think
joe biden or at least joe biden of 20
years ago would believe
we had three justices next time around
we lose control they had three justices
we began to lose any credibility for the
court has it all
all right let's move on uh white
supremacy people
it's back it never goes anywhere unless
you've condemned white supremacy
every half hour on the half hour for the
last 10 months
you yourself are a white supremacist i
believe i read that in the
merriam-webster dictionary of white
supremacy
but trump was asked by savannah guthrie
about white supremacy and the q anon
conspiracy theory let's take a look you
were asked point blank
to denounce white supremacy in the
moment
you didn't you asked some follow-up
questions who specifically
a couple of days later on a different
show you denounced white supremacy
the question is you've done this to me
and everybody seemed like
i denounced white supremacy okay you
didn't do
white supremacy for years but you always
do it you always start off with the
question you didn't ask joe biden
whether or not he denounces antifa
i watched him on the same basic show
with lester holt
and he was asking questions like biden
was a child
are you listening i denounce white
supremacy okay what's your next question
do you feel
it feels sometimes you're hesitant to do
so like you waited here we go again
every time in fact my people came i'm
sure they'll ask you the white supremacy
question
i denounce white supremacy and frankly
you want to know something
i denounce antifa and i denounce these
people on the left that are burning down
our cities that are run by democrats who
don't
while we're denouncing let me ask you
about q anon it
is this theory that uh
democrats are a satanic pedophile ring
and that you
are the savior of that now can you just
once and for all state that that is
completely not true
in its entirety i know nothing about q
anon
i just talked i know very little you
told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact i hate to say
that
i know nothing about it i do know they
are very much
against uh pedophilia they fight it very
hard
but i know nothing about it believe it
or
not
i'll tell you what i do know about i
know about antifa and i know about the
radical left and i know how violent they
are and how vicious they are
and i know how they are burning down
cities run by democrats not wrong
republican senator ben sasse said quote
q anon is
nuts and real leaders call conspiracy
theories
conspiracy theories why not just say
it's crazy and not true
he may be right i just don't know about
q anon you do know
i don't know no i don't know i don't
know let me ask you another thing let's
waste the whole show
uh you start off with white supremacy i
denounce it
you start off with something else let's
go keep asking me these questions
let me just let me just tell you what i
do hear about it is they are very
strongly against pedophilia
and i agree with that i mean i do agree
with that and i agree with you there's
not a satanic
uh pedophile i have no idea i know you
don't know that
okay no i don't know you just do this
okay just this week
what are you asking me about antifa why
aren't you asking me about the radicals
are you asking joe biden questions about
why doesn't he condem antifa why does he
say it doesn't exist because you're here
that's so cute antifa exists
they're vicious they're violent they
kill people and they're burning down our
cities
and they happen to be radical left okay
we played the whole portion of that for
you because i actually think that was
just trump at his best
he absolutely hit back on the white
supremacy stuff
we know and especially if you guys are
watching this show
he has denounced white supremacy roughly
four billion times including right after
charlottesville even though savannah
guthrie and nbc news and cnn
and abc and the rest of them won't show
that clip where he absolutely condemns
white supremacy and the kkk and the
neo-nazis and the rest of it
so he was really laser focused this this
was sort of the answer that he needed to
give last time
and when savannah guthrie kept saying
you didn't condemn it that night he
repeatedly said
sure now it was a muddled answer and he
should have he should have answered it
better
and he was saying who should i condemn
specifically so i'm not
defending that he muddled that answer
and biden was they were all talking at
the same time okay fine
um but this was was him directly
answering it and then the q anon stuff
she's laughing as she says it because
they just want to get him
talking about a q anon conspiracy theory
and i think his his response to it was
quite good which is from what i hear
about them i don't know that much about
them from what i hear about them they're
against pedophilia can we agree that
pedophilia is bad well
now suddenly because everyone decides
what they believe based on what trump is
against
or for well now you're gonna have a
whole bunch of people apparently on the
left they're gonna be for pedophilia
uh the whole thing is so stupid but the
way she laughs about it
and you know you can't condemn it it's
like how can i condemn a thing i don't
really know about but if
if the idea is there against pedophilia
then yeah i'm against pedophilia
but just that sort of tension that
ridiculous tension are you against white
supremacy we know the answer and now
let's talk about are you against
the conspiracy theory about it's like
it's so
driveless and stupid i'm not even sure
dribblist is a word but if it isn't a
word uh i'd like to make it a word that
was just pure drivel and stupidity
all right let's move on to the next one
uh this
is oh people are going crazy about this
a lot of people are angry about this
there was a black woman behind trump and
she seemed to be
in agreement with the president 30
seconds what would you say to them
because they've done a great job
we had the strongest economy in the
world we closed it up
we are coming around the corner the
vaccines are coming out soon
anyway yes that black woman
thumbs up nodding with the president and
there were a lot of blue check
people on twitter journalists who were
very upset that that woman was showing
emotion and agreeing
it's obviously propaganda it's not
propaganda when you have a democrat
grilling him about conspiracy theories
and whether he's a white supremacist
but if a black person agrees and thumbs
up with the president we got a real
problem on our hands so
it's just it's just i just want you guys
to see like the
theater nature of all of this craziness
uh but as long as we're
talking about black people let's talk
about black empowerment
uh this is trump and biden we're gonna
show you two clips
we'll show you first one come back show
you the second one both of them
on black empowerment here we go i have
done more for the african-american
community than any
president with the exception of abraham
lincoln criminal justice reform
prison reform historically black
colleges and universities i got them
funded they were on a year-to-year basis
they could have been put out of business
as soon as our country had a little bad
year they would have said i'm sorry
we're not going to fund you i got them
10-year
funding and financing and more than they
even asked for i became very friendly
with a lot of the heads
but we've done more and of course
opportunity zones
but criminal justice reform everybody
said it could
it could not be done president obama and
biden never even tried to do it they
never even tried
all right i mean that's a pretty solid
answer right like when
when these people are asked questions
they usually dance around things trump
gave a bunch of stuff there right
criminal justice reform and it's true
prison reform
and it's true funding historically black
colleges
and it's true these are real things on
top of the fact
that let's not forget right before the
covid thing when trump gave the state of
the union address
he was talking about record low black
unemployment record low black
unemployment and the congressional
caucus the congressional the black
congressional caucus and all of the
democrats sat there and you can watch
the video don't take my word for watch
the video
they sat there like this now i would
think
i know call me crazy i would think that
if if you're four black people
right if you're four americans who
happen to be black you might
applaud when the president says they
having the lowest unemployment of all
time
so those were those were solid answers
that he gave there
and i think that plays well and i've
been saying it for quite some time but i
think the black vote is gonna
is gonna break tremendously uh towards
trump this time i'm not saying it's
gonna be over 50
i mean usually it's something like eight
percent i tweeted out about a year ago i
think it's going to be like 30
but even if it's 15 or 20 that would be
incredible and i think there's a lot of
evidence of that i actually i just had
candace owens for dinner
last night and what she's done with
blexit and with all these people
you know uh black voices for trump and
what brandon tatum's doing and the
message of thomas soul that's getting
out there i think something shocking is
gonna happen because trump is right
if you guys were so into helping black
people you guys meaning
obama biden the democrats before well
then what did you do did you guys have
record low black unemployment what did
you do obviously whatever you did didn't
work if it's all terrible right now
which is what the left is telling us
well then you guys either didn't do
anything or you failed at everything
so prison reform criminal justice reform
funding the historically black colleges
that is something but all right let's uh
let's take a look
and see what biden said to basically the
same question many people believe that
the true swing demographic in this
election will be black voters under the
age of 30
not because they'll be voting for trump
but because they won't vote at all
i myself have had this exact same
conflict so my question for you then is
besides you ain't black what do you have
to say to young black voters who see
voting for you
as further participation in a system
that continually fails to protect them
well i'd say first of all as my buddy
john lewis said it's a sacred
opportunity to write to vote you can
make a difference
if young black women and men vote you
can determine the outcome of this
election
not a joke you can do that and the next
question is
am i worthy of your vote can i earn your
vote and the answer
is there's two things i think that i
care and i've demonstrated i care about
my whole career
one is in addition to dealing with a
criminal justice system to make it fair
and make it more decent we have to be
able to put black americans to be able
to
gain wealth generate wealth and so you
look at what
that entails and it tells everything
from early education that's why i'm
supporting making sure that
we entitle one schools as you know
schools with the least tax
base to be able to support their schools
i increased the funding for them from 15
to
45 billion dollars that allows every
teacher in that school
to make up to 60 000 bucks and the
problem now is they're leaving the
schools they're not there
we're short about a million and a half
teachers a million and a quarter
teachers
number two every three and four and
five-year-old will go to school
school not daycare school with all the
great universities including the one
you've gone to
go to or went to in fact talks about in
the last eight years
what's happened what happens when you
let them go to school
they make up rapidly than whatever
whatever
um fail whatever shortcoming they had in
terms of their education prior to that
they've have not heard as many words
spoken etc etc
what happens is that the studies show
that 58
will increase by 58 their chance to go
in all through uh 12 years of school
and going through successfully well
that goes on for another four minutes or
so i'm not really sure what joe said he
increased something from
15 billion to 45 billion
let's just say that's true i'm not
really sure what he's talking about did
it do anything i mean that's the
question when he's
he says the phrase criminal justice
reform but
did he do anything and the answer this
is the
this is the trouble with the entire
biden
operation is that if any of the things
that he says he would do
now he did well then people wouldn't be
in this tough situation
and if he didn't do them before then why
would you trust him to do it this time
so he says criminal justice
reform but it obviously didn't work out
that well because now trump is actually
doing it this is just
true that this is not partisan craziness
the rest of it was a meandering answer
that i'm just completely
confused by and it went on and on and on
i just can't do that to you good people
you have things to do
i assume some of you work i can't just
play these things and
have you lose half your day um you know
he also said something about early
education and
and whatever and it's just like i just
don't know what he's saying
honestly it's like i don't know what
he's saying and it's like man if you
knew how to fix any of these things
then why didn't you do it and if and if
your argument is that you did do it
well then i think a lot of people are
going well all right it didn't work so i
i just think that's a that's a tough
loss and a bad answer and let's uh let's
just do one more
and this is biden on on policing because
his answer was
was a little bizarre here let's throw to
the videotape
we can do this you can ban choke holes
you can but
but beyond that you have to teach people
how to de-escalate circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
to kill
you shoot them in a leg there's ways you
have to do more background checks in
terms of whether or not
the person coming in past a certain
psychological test and the last thing
i'll say and i'm sorry because
what's really i think really really
important is you have to be in a
position where
you are able to identify identify
the things that have to change and one
of the things has to change is
so many cops get called into
circumstances where somebody is mentally
off like what happened not long ago that
guy with the knife
that's why we have to provide within
police departments
psychologists and social workers to go
out
with the cops on those calls those some
of those 911 de-escalate the
circumstance
to deal with talking them down but we
can't
cops are kind of like school teachers
yes
there's someone mentally off i'm just
not sure
it's the person joe thinks um okay there
was a lot in that answer this idea
that he proposed that that's what cops
are doing that they get out there
ready to shoot to kill that's just crazy
and that there isn't training
that stops them from doing it of course
that's not what they do
cops don't get out there this is just
true cops are not trained to get out
there and shoot to kill
they go out of their way virtually every
time in often chaotics
crazy situations not to kill people and
most
times they don't kill people regardless
of their skin color so this idea that we
need more training to
to teach them not to kill as if they're
this like mass
murdering force that's occupying the
streets is actually it's offensive and
just crazy the idea also that we don't
have psychological tests he's implying
that we don't have psychological tests
to make sure these people are okay that
become police officers they
they have to go through all sorts of
testing now i will give him credit on
one thing this idea that perhaps
we because a lot of the incidences that
police officers are called to involve
mental health right so there's people
that are on drugs
there's people with mental health
problems there are people that are
potentially suicidal
all sorts of things that could you have
psychologists potentially
or could you have social workers
potentially alongside the cops to help
de-escalate situations well that seems
like something
that's worth exploring i think it's one
of those things that probably sounds
more sensible than it actually is right
if a cop shows up somewhere
and there's a mentally ill person with a
knife or with a gun threatening somebody
and everything else it's like
there may not be time to have someone
you know could you could you sit down
and lay down on the couch and
tell me about your mother but i think
the idea of it as
is at least worth exploring or perhaps
perhaps some more
training about mental health for police
officers uh
related to the people that they're
dealing with um i think potentially is
something there but again this is stuff
that it's like okay if this is so
obvious and if this has been going on
for so long that we've been training
cops to get out there and
and just murder people instead of
shooting him in the leg it's like well
where were you on all this joe you've
been
in biz right you've been in the
government for
47 years so again why didn't you do
criminal justice
before reform before why didn't you do
prison reform why didn't you stop the
murderous cops
before why didn't you do all those
things why didn't you stop racism and
everything else and
i think you guys all kind of know the
answers to that anyway people i hope
that gave you a
sensible taste of what the non-debates
were like last night hopefully there
will be one more debate it still seems a
little
a little up in the air oh and by the way
i should mention one other thing because
the mainstream media is not really
covering this but you know the debate
was supposed to be covered by this
c-span guy originally when they had
scheduled the debate the moderator was
going to be this uh
this c-span anchor who then claimed that
his twitter account
was hacked and c-span backed him up and
all of these people were defending him
because it was basically coming out that
you know
well he also i think had interned did he
had he interned for biden i think he had
interned for biden at one point
yada yada it turns out that he's now
been suspended because his account
wasn't hacked i mean it's just all
craziness
his name is steve scully you guys can
google that story anyway the adventure
continued guys
have a great weekend everybody we will
be back next week with more interviews
more direct messages more craziness
before the election
and i'll see you then bye